the end is near on yellowstone's
apocalyptic season 4 finale as the
vision quest leads to a grim prediction
of the future season 4 of yellowstone
began in the aftermath of a literal bang
a season 3 finale which saw casey beth
and john dutton targeted and a
coordinated hit on the family after a
brief jump forward in time season 4 sees
the dutton family and the yellowstone
dutton ranch employees get placed on new
more high-stakes paths john and jamie
dutton enter into a gubernatorial race
the duttons fend off threats like market
equities and broken rock reservation
beth struggles with both an unsteady
recovery and an effort to figure out who
tried to hurt her and her family the
fourth season of yellowstone similarly
goes out with a bang as jimmy herdstrom
leaves the yellowstone dutton ranch for
greener pastures in existence outside
the cowboy way of life with his fiancee
emily john expresses his disappointment
with jimmy's decision especially in
light to the ranch's shaky future but
allows him to leave tensions between
caroline warner and beth reach an
all-time high resulting in her firing
from market equities later she's
re-embraced by her dutton kin elsewhere
casey tries to figure out how to best
proceed with his life and receives a
seemingly dire proclamation casey's
always been a complicated character on
the show but the place where season 4
leaves casey is especially noteworthy
here's why at the end of season 4 casey
goes on a deeply transformative vision
quest he takes himself to a patch of
deserted land and embarks on a spiritual
journey that opens old wounds forces him
to deal with past traumas and teases the
end of someone or something in season 5.
alone in cold casey experiences several
flashes of memory that leave him shaken
these flashes include visions of his
dead brother lee dutton who appears just
outside of the protected area where
casey must sit during his quest at
another point in the vision quest casey
has plunged into his memories of his
time serving in the navy where audiences
get a clear glimpse into the horrors the
youngest dutton experienced while
serving as his vision quest nears the
end the appearance of a young girl leads
casey to the top of a hill there he's
presented with two possible paths and is
told the girl will help him walk the one
he picks but he must decide the way his
wife monica later asks him what he's
seen casey tells her i saw the universe
it's an ominous revelation especially
because it's unclear what casey is
referring to it could be the duttons
whose ownership of the ranch is as
integral to their sense of identity as
their lives it could also refer to
casey's relationship with monica which
has been tested repeatedly throughout
the show casey's dreadfilled statement
has quickly become a source of much
speculation amongst yellowstone fans
several interpretations have been
suggested by fans who hang out on the
yellowstone subreddit as they debate
what casey's final line of season 4
ultimately means in the grand scheme of
the show's future redditors shared their
mixed opinions about what these eerie
words could mean one commenter wrote did
he mean the end of him and monica the
end of the human race the end of the
duttons or the ranch or the end of their
town or way of life they also added that
monica seemed to understand what casey
was getting at another redditor
suggested that the two pass represent
casey being forced to pick between his
relationship with monica and saving the
dutton-ranching empire whichever path he
chooses the other relationship will be
ended meanwhile another redditor wrote
that the divided path represents casey's
choice between the white world of the
duttons and the indigenous world of
monica and her family who were fighting
to get their land back from the duttons
whether or not any of these theories are
correct fans will have to wait for
season 5 of yellowstone to see what
happens
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
yellowstone are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you